[Musique]
et vous avez tous les jours ce qui est
ainsi extraordinaire c'est difficile à
imaginer tous les jours tout le jour
tous les jours et tous les jours les je
me lève tard maintenant étant donné que
je suis obligé un astre un repos de
toutes les matinées mais gevrey de mon
courrier dans la matinée puis à près de
2 heures 7 heures j'écris toutes et tous
les après midi c'est le plaisir pur de
leur expérience et d'un plaisir
véritablement sans aucun mélange de
décrire d'écrire de me livrer ce travail
de marqueterie qu'est le style le
remplacer tellement par une virgule ou
en place et 7,1 par un adverbe ont
allongé la phrase ou la raccourcir
sentir le rythme se faire ou le chercher
se heurter contre les difficultés à voir
voir naître mais de l'est va par le
caractère vous remettre le style ou
parfois par le style va renaître les
caractères des personnages
donc ça c'est mon plaisir personnel une
fois que cet écrit mon plaisir est
infinie est terminée et nous pouvons se
continuer que dans un nouvelle écriture
le reste voir un livre édité ou
m'intéresser à son sort ne ferait que
ralentir mon bonheur ou le retarder et
c'est pourquoi je suis une mousse un
procès que les la majorité des écrivains
et spécialement des jeunes écrivains ne
vois pas les choses cette magie qui se
dépêchent tue parce qu'ils ne veulent
pas voir où ils veulent l'argent ni
volta d'été zone est révoltant dans des
quantités sont immenses et pousser il
venait d'avoir rejoué dans la société
heaven famille des quantités de choses
ici sont étonnés ensuite ne pas avoir le
bonheur c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas
voulu
le voleur est à côté tout ce qu'ils
veulent voilà n'aurait eu qu'à le
vouloir s'il avait voulu le bonheur il
n'aurait pas cherché et on n'aurait pas
atteindre sur tout ce qu'ils ont cherché
qui n'est pas le bonheur le bonheur est
à côté
le moteur est en dehors de toutes ces
recherches de deux gloires d'argent de
bonheur le bonheur tout à fait à part
[Musique]
vous avez toujours été aussi un lecteur
un peu à part je crois surtout beaucoup
je lis beaucoup
je lis énormément une très grande
bibliothèque comme je suis un grand
lecteur d'instruction nautique
oui qu'est-ce que ça vous avez les
instructions nautique c'est la
description de toutes les cotes du monde
à émettre près on voit toutes les coupes
du monde
une plaque de goémon d'un mètre est
décrite tout tout est décrit une tout
sur une plage un amer représenté par un
poteau télégraphique en nouvelle zélande
est représenté sur le est décrite et
alors c'est écrit dans un style
extraordinaire qu'a sepsis ou puisqu'ils
sont destinés au capitaine de vaisseau
qui doivent les livres rapidement parce
que thor besoin de prendre des décisions
très rapide c'est c'est l'équivalent de
ce que stendhal avait le code civil la
qualité des soins optiques on a des
exemples de style extraordinaire
habilité à whitby la clarté c'est votre
manière de voyager oui voyage rock ce
livre je voyais partir de quantité
d'autres choses il suffit par exemple de
de moisissures sur un mur vous qu'on
imagine une admirable carte géographique
est là dedans à travers laquelle on peut
faire de magnifiques voyages
vous pensez qu'en général les hommes
d'aujourd'hui ont trop besoin d'aller
vérifier sur place et de faire effectuer
ces pages comprend mal leur curiosité
cette curiosité est à base d'ennuis et
elle ne quitte pas l'ennui même quand
elle est satisfaite quand elle se
satisfait j'ai beaucoup de plaisir au
contraire moi faire travailler mon
imagination je suis jamais déçu
[Musique]